you guys I am back for another
instructive video and it's possible that
anyone who religiously follows my my
videos my streams may have watched a
stream that I did yesterday where I
think it was the first game I played
against the Petrov and I went into this
line after E 4 E 5
I have 396 I played d4 and then after
the game I was trying to recall uh this
a nice giri game from several years ago
wherein each lost and in like under 25
moves so i found the game and i wanted
to make a video of just me analyzing the
game I don't think I've done this before
where I just go over like a high level
GM game just as its own video so
hopefully this will be instructive
hopefully if there's any four players
out there who don't know what to play
against the petrov you can learn a thing
or two from this because d4 isn't the
most popular move I think these days
white usually takes on e5 but d4 is very
playable and as we'll see in this game
it has some some venom especially if if
White's prepared and maybe black isn't
so well prepared so the main line here
is after night a key for white can take
on e5 and I had this think I had this
position in my game yesterday and I was
hesitant to take on e5 because of this
move Bishop c5 it turns out after Bishop
c5 White has a nice response and now I
should note the white player in this
game was salt on Almasy another super GM
we should also note that uh nigiri is
one of the most solid players in the
world very good at at drawing pretty
much anyone so it's very impressive that
Almasy won this game is seemingly so
easily so the move white plays here is a
bit surprising because f2 is attacked
and it seems like white should defend
somehow maybe with a move like Bishop e3
but this is why I was hesitant to go in
to this line because white doesn't
really want to play Bishop III and leads
to just damaged pawn structure so white
plays a nice counter-attacking move
Bishop to c4 sacrificing f2 so back to
excel f2 and now the main idea for white
is to take on f7 and now it leads to
some really interesting line after King
take F 7 Queen d5 check the king is
essentially being ripped from its it's
shelter if it goes back to a square like
Yeates then white is just I think
winning material after Bishop g5 almost
trapping the Queen forcing Bishop e7 and
then after take-take-take
white is uh way top material here why
does not up material but white has a
really nice position
easy development black is almost not at
all developed the works from coming very
easily and I would be happy here as
white so going back they go into the
main line instead of king - Yeats Bach
plays king g6 which is already looking a
bit suspicious but this position has
occurred before if we check in the
database here there's been ok there's
been two games on Lee chess and there's
been more in the Masters database yeah
there's been just over a dozen in the
Masters database so it's still some some
sort of theory
this game al masih takes on c5 and I
take h1 and then they're in a situation
where black is up material but the
King's on g6 and the Knights on each one
and I feel like if you're going to go
into this as White's and you're you're
well prepared maybe you're supported
with computer preparation and it's the
line to go into just because I mean it's
so difficult for black to the fend as
we'll see in what happened this game so
Knight c3 is played and then Garry plays
a smooth d6 which i think is a novelty
at least was a novelty at the time we
can quickly check the opening stats here
h6 is played almost exclusively and
anyone who's serious about studying this
line further I would recommend to look
deeper into this movie h6 and actually I
didn't note this but this is part of a
leach a study which I will share in the
video description so anyone who wants to
look over these lines a bit closer and
maybe add your own analysis you can do
so everything is saved here and you can
see my my brief annotations so what I've
done here I've I've pasted two games one
game was between special cotton Friedman
whereas fester cough one very smoothly
and then another game was against or
between turgut's
and mole and this was actually a
correspondence scheme Hansel Turgut is
actually a friend of mine and he's one
of the top correspondence players in the
world
and they went into like a really crazy
computer line variation where if you
turn on stock fish it says Black's
winning but it got really messy so I'm
not gonna go into this now but if anyone
wants to take a look the games are
included in this in this chapter so
going back to the mainline pawn g6 and
why plays Queen c4 which is really nice
move somewhat of a multi-purpose move as
white wants to keep the Queen on c4 may
be supporting 9 h4 check also there's
many thematic ideas of Knight e5 just
bringing a piece closer to the king
targeting c7 so that's still under
pressure here so gary plays h6 turn off
opening book 95
and here black is is under serious
pressure because my take c7 is a threat
and I'm at Kingston on g6 and blacks not
developed and here at Gary played the
losing move I think what he should have
done is play c6 and then there's some
line Knight f4 check King h7 Queen d3
King g8 and then taking on d6 this is
just the stockfish line that I was
researching earlier and it seems like
white has great compensation for for
being down at rook because this Knight
is eventually going to be lost then
white will only be down the exchange the
D pawn looks very strong so yeah this
looks very playable so going back what
I'm gonna do is put this on training
mode or essentially the chest training
mode where people can't see the notation
because there is a nice exercise coming
up after rook F eights hopefully people
didn't look earlier and see what White's
going to do here but I will show the
next the next move Queen B for King to
f7 and then if I'm not mistaken I think
this is a position this is white so move
and find the strongest move
I believe there's only one winning move
here or for white so if you want to
pause the video find the strongest move
but I'll go ahead and show it move as
bishop take h6 which is just just
crushing the idea is that after what
happened the game pawn take aged six
I can play Queen age seven and the King
just has no no safe place I take C seven
is coming like King e6 or King yeats I
take C seven I believe just wins the
Queen so the game just ended really
quickly after King Yeates
I take C seven Queen 67 Queen takes e7
white now has a queen for a rook and a
bishop also white has what two extra
pawns so Gary tried to
somehow survived but White's technique
was just too strong wasn't too difficult
to convert this position just keep
grabbing pawns and then oh did I say
queen for a rook and Bishop I meant
Queen for a rook Bishop and Knight but
because white just has so many extra
pawns and blacks not really coordinated
and the King is just so exposed it will
see how white wins wins this drag queen
h5 yeah the King has no safe place he's
six and black resigned here given that
Knight take a5 is coming and yeah what
to do yeah so that's how you beat a nice
giri in 22 moves the the more important
point I think from this is to perhaps
look at the opening a bit closer
especially in such a sharp variation
resulting from its very early bishops to
c4
I think this is a cool line especially
players who might prefer crazier types
of positions more attacking types of
positions I think this is a nice line
against the petrov there's a lot of
Petroff players are are perhaps a bit I
will say boring in nature but maybe a
bit more solid in nature so this is a
type of line which can go up against the
style of a Petroff player so I hope you
guys enjoyed that again I'll leave the
link to the study in the description if
you want to add your own analysis what
you can do in Li chess is clone the
study which if you look below the board
you get these buns you would click this
and then clone which we can't see when
you zoom in clone right here and then
that will take you to a page where you
basically create a duplicate of the
study and then you can you can do
whatever you want with it and probably
what I'll do in the future is I will I
will just add more chapters to the study
right now there's
one chapter zoom in here but the more
types of game analysis i do i'll just
keep adding games so people can access
some easily so I'll end it there thanks
for watching and I will see you guys in
the future